[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend es kommt selten vor dass es
im europäischen parlament so hoch her
geht wie heute und das waren eigentlich
nicht parlamentarier und fraktionen die
entlang üblicher parteilinien
gegeneinander redeten sondern es standen
sich grundüberzeugungen und
staatengruppen gegenüber auf der einen
seite die mehrheit der europäer die auf
die einhaltung von rechtsstaats
prinzipien behaupten auf der anderen
seite eine minderheit angeführt von
polen und ungarn
parlamentarische unterstützung bekam sie
heute nur aus den reihen der
rechtspopulisten
anlass war der auftritt des polnischen
regierungschefs der darauf beharrt dass
die eu den polen rechtlich nichts zu
sagen habe das widerspricht jedoch den
europäischen verträgen wie sein land
beim eu-beitritt unterschrieb und so ist
inzwischen sogar von einem austritt
polen steht anna krüger berichtet
ist der gast spricht und spricht
bis der vorsitzende bittet sie müssen
zum ende kommen
die mahnung offenbart hinter den worten
herrscht sprachlosigkeit zwischen polens
regierung und der eu
vielen dank herr premier wenn sie die
redezeit einhalten dann zeigen sie auch
respekt vor dem hohen haus der
europäischen demokratie
der applaus hat gründe denn erstens
velten regierungstreue richter in
warschau ein urteil teile der eu
verträge seien unvereinbar mit polens
verfassung zweitens gängelt polen seit
jahren richter zuletzt mit einer
disziplinarkammer
radek sikorski war mal außenminister ist
murat jetzt kies gegner aber heute
gefragt als erklärer diese kammer ist
das eigentliche problem denn sie
verletzt polens verfassung die
eu-verträge und das prinzip eines jeden
modernen staates die gewaltenteilung
darum die debatte heute darum der gast
der sich selbst einlud ein premier im
parlament dazu die kommissionschefin das
hätte ein austausch werden können und
wurde ein schlagabtausch
der pole rechtfertigt das urteil eu
recht gehe vor aber eben nicht dort wo
die eu ihre kompetenzen überschreite und
das passiere immer öfter
die europäische union ist kein staat die
staaten sind europa souverän und sie
sind herren der verträge sie entscheiden
welche kompetenzen sie
sieht sich als hüterin der verträge und
in dem urteil und in der kammer noch
immer eine kampfansage wir
können und wir werden nicht zulassen
dass unsere gemeinsamen werte in gefahr
geraten die kommission wird handeln und
unsere optionen sind wohlbekannt
aber noch immer zieht sie keine die
klage vom ogh ignoriert polen einstimmen
zug dem verfahren nach artikel 7
blockiert ungarn der rechtsstaats
mechanismus greift nur bei missbrauch
von eu geld bleibt der aufbau von die
kommission sperrt vorerst 730 milliarden
euro was zumindest eins hervorruft
kein politiker oder fressen finanzielle
erpressung darf kein mittel der politik
sein doch genau das fordern die mehrheit
der abgeordneten im europaparlament der
moral jetzt hören sie auf zu zünden das
hier ist kein spiel wie schlafwandeln
richtung eu austritt gegen den willen
ihrer europäischen freunde und gegen den
willen vor allem des polnischen volkes
der ton der debatte war ziemlich
aggressiv aber ich hoffe gegen alle
vernunft dass es noch einen ausweg gibt
der könne darin bestehen dass polen die
disziplinarkammer für richter abschafft
übermorgen ist eu-gipfel für die
europäischen freunde die nächste chance
murat jetzt die zu überzeugen
jan dramatischer tag in straßburg
darüber wollen wir mit manfred weber
sprechen dem vorsitzenden der
christdemokratischen cvp fraktion im
europäischen parlament
guten abend erleben
hallo guten am drücker sie sind ja heute
in der debatte auch aufgetreten und
haben gesagt wer die unabhängigkeit der
rechtsordnung in frage stellt der tritt
faktisch als mitgliedsland aus dass das
klang jetzt wird sich schon sehr nach
poll exit also fast nach einer
empfehlung liebe polen wenn ihr nicht
mögt dann trete doch auch
das ist die realität wenn man heute die
rede des polnischen premierministers
zugehört hat hört sehr klar seine
positionen formuliert und für mich ist
es heute sehr ernster tag zum ersten mal
haben wir eine regierung die die
unabhängigkeit der eigenen gerichte
infrage stellt vor allem des obersten
gerichtshofs es gab schon immer mal
debatten auch bei uns inzwischen
karlsruhe und dem europäischen
gerichtshof das nationale europäische
gerichte im ringen miteinander das ist
normal das gehört zum normalen
rechtsstaat dazu aber dass ein
gerichtshof nicht mehr unabhängig ist
das ist so fundamental und wenn dann der
polnische premier ist auch noch
verteidigt und nicht selbstkritisch auch
überlegt dann haben wenn europa echtes
problem der premier hat ja eben auch auf
dieses beispiel was die jetzt zb werden
bundesverfassungsgericht hatte eine
entscheidung des europäischen
gerichtshofs da ging es um geldpolitik
der ezb kritisiert wurde sogar ein
verfahren von der kommission gegen
deutschland eingeleitet also erstellt
das eigentlich eine ebene und sagten
andere wollen das auch nicht mehr hier
vom europäischen gerichtshof gegängelt
werden wo liegt da für sie der
entscheidende unterschied
entscheidende unterschied ist dass der
restlichen obersten gerichte der
mitgliedstaaten der europäischen union
unabhängig sind wenn die richter berufen
sind wie bei uns in karlsruhe dann
entscheiden sie in aller unabhängigkeit
nach rechtslage und dass es in polen
nicht mehr der fall das ist mehrfach
durch gerichte europaweit bestätigt
wurden auch viele deutsche gerichte
haben sorgen über das was in polen
passiert es ist nicht nur das oberste
gericht sondern auch normale gerichte in
polen sind mittlerweile betroffen davon
wir erleben eine politisierung der
justiz
und damit wird die hausordnung der
europäischen frage gestellt wir sind
eine nicht eine wirtschaftsgemeinschaft
in erster in die wir sind eine
wertegemeinschaft und eine recht
gemeinschaft wir vertrauen darauf dass
demokratie die unabhängigkeit der justiz
der rechtsstaat eben hoch gehalten wird
in allen staaten und deswegen gibt es da
jetzt kein wackeln europa muss handeln
und meine erwartungshaltung vor allem
gegenüber dem europäischen rat also den
staats und regierungschefs wenn sich die
jetzt am donnerstag und freitag treffen
es muss nach diesem tag im europäischen
parlament auch bei den chefs klartext
geredet werden wir können nicht zur
tagesordnung übergehen es geht um
grundsatzfragen nun haben wir bei einem
europäischen rat an die staats und
regierungschefs am donnerstag freitag
wieder zusammensitzen das problem dass
die ja keine mehrheit für eine
entscheidung haben zum beispiel polen
das stimmrecht zu entziehen da wird
ungarn dagegen seien auch slowenien
vielleicht auch andere staaten
tschechien das heißt da findet sich
keine mehrheit insofern was erwarten sie
von dem rad was soll er dann tun
zunächst ist die kommission am zug der
kommission seite können wir gelder
blockieren und ich erwarte von ursula
von der leyen und der eu kommission dass
sie die gelder die jetzt bereit stehen
um nach der korona pandemie die
wirtschaft wieder aufzubauen dass diese
gelder gegenüber polen blockiert bleiben
solange diese unabhängige justiz nicht
endgültig geklärt ist und da brauchen
wir taten und nicht nur worte von polen
und sie verweisen zu recht auf die
sitzung dann diese woche beim rat dort
steht der zweite debattieren nämlich den
artikel 7 sie sagen zu recht dass wir
eine einstimmige entscheidung brauchen
und polen die stimmrechte zu entziehen
das werden wahrscheinlich im sitzen
starten das vermeiden und verhindern
wollen aber bisher muss ich das einfach
mal vorstellen seit 2017 läuft ein
artikel sieben verfahren einen
rechtsstaat verfahren gegen um gegen
polen und bisher konnte bei den staats
und regierungschefs noch nicht einmal
darüber diskutiert werden und bis heute
abend wissen wir nicht ob schallt
michelle der präsident des europäischen
rates die debatte über polen überhaupt
auf die tagesordnung nimmt aus meiner
sicht ist es ein skandal angesichts der
entwicklungen die wir heute im
europäischen parlament erlebt haben muss
die frage vordringlich im europäischen
rat diskutiert werden und da muss
gegenüber polen klartext gesprochen
werden aber wie gesagt artikel 7 das
braucht einstimmigkeit und wenn es dann
eskaliert und am ende läuft man dann
damit wegen der standarte in die
schlacht und kommt mit hängendem
fähnchen wieder raus und hat von da an
empfohlen da sitzen dass alle
entscheidungen künftig blockiert und
sich sozusagen dann auch recht für so
etwas das ist eigentlich kann kein
zustand also helfen solche
verfahrensfragen überhaupt um einen
gemeinsamen weg zu finden wie
die geldfragen helfen sicher weil polen
auch sehr stark von den geldern abhängig
ist aber es reicht natürlich nicht nur
über wirtschaftliche maßnahme entspricht
über gelder die ausbezahlt werden druck
zu machen sondern wir müssen reden
miteinander das ist eine grundsatzfrage
dem raum steht und wir dürfen da auch
der polnischen regierung nicht zulassen
dass sie sich da einfach raus redet im
sinne von das sind dabei rechtsfragen
der juristen klären sollen es geht um
grundsatzfragen und ich finde politisch
mussten müssen die staats und
regierungschefs erweitere frage klären
einer der sich am meisten freude wird
diese debatte ist vladimir putin in
moskau er freut sich weil der
rechtsstaat zur debatte steht in der
europäischen union nicht mehr garantiert
wird und er freut sich weil wir intern
streiten er will ein zerstrittenes
europa und das muss man den polnischen
freunden sehr sehr klar sagen bitte hört
auf mit dieser provokation bitte hört
auf den rechtsstaat zu attackieren es
werden nur unsere externe gegner sich
freuen und das kann nicht unser ziel
sein herr weber danken für das gespräch
ich bedanke mich
als interviewer haben aus termingründen
aufgezeichnet nachher im heute-journal
update spricht nazan guckte mir zu dem
thema mit dem europarechtler und
ausgewiesenen polen kennern professor
franz meyer
winter ist coming davor warnen virologen
sein wochen auch hier in deutschland
aber diese warnrufe scheinen bislang
weitgehend zu verhalten was auch daran
liegen dürfte dass die geimpften sich
relativ sicher fühlen ungeimpfte
erwachsene wiederum gehören mehrheitlich
zumindest ähnlich zu denen die sich
wegen corona große sorgen machen sei es
aus unkenntnis oder desinformation
tatsache ist jedenfalls die zahlen
steigen wieder von woche zu woche
das robert koch institut meldete
6771 neuinfektionen innerhalb eines
tages das sind 1800 mehr als vor einer
woche
88 todesfälle kamen binnen 24 stunden
hinzu die sieben tage incidents liegt
inzwischen bei 75 comma 1
was es bedeutet wenn die winter welle
auf eine hohe zahl ungeimpfter trifft
lässt sich derzeit in rumänien
beobachten die impfquote dort ist
besonders niedrig die folgen fatal wolf
christian ullrich berichtet
in diesem krankenhaus in cluj gibt es
nicht mal mehr eine freie trage selbst
die notaufnahme ist durch corona
patienten blockiert die nicht mehr auf
die intensivstation passen vor der tür
werden ratlose retter abgewiesen
wir finden keinen platz für die
patienten sagt dieser fahrer das
krankenhaus ist voll jetzt versuchen wir
ein anderes zu finden
die ärzte sprechen von der schlimmsten
situation seit dem beginn der pandemie
die intensivstation ist seit wochen voll
wenn ein bett frei wird dann meistens
weil jemand gestorben ist unter den
schweren fällen auch der intensivstation
haben die allermeisten keine info
während ungeimpfte corona patienten im
krankenhaus um ihr leben kämpfen stellen
sich in der hauptstadt bukarest
impfgegner auf die straße und
protestieren gegen die korona maßnahmen
masken pflicht und der grüne corona pass
sind unpopulär und werden nicht überall
durchgesetzt mitten in der aktuellen
corona krise zerbrach nun auch noch die
regierung entsprechend wenig autorität
hat der interims regierungschef wenn er
etwa für die impfung wird
wenn nicht geimpft ist sollte das
dringend tun das ist jetzt die einzige
lösung
nicht mal ein drittel der rumänischen
bevölkerung ist vollständig geimpft der
grund dafür jahrzehnte der diktatur und
die korrupten nach wenn die regierungen
haben das vertrauen der menschen in ihre
politische führung nachhaltig zerstört
außerdem fehlt es vor allem auf dem land
ein corona aufklären und
schauergeschichten im internet tun ihr
übriges
das problem ist vor allem desinformation
und dann ist der bildungsgrad in
rumänien auch ziemlich gering
die autoritäten lügen uns doch an nehmen
sie mal ihre kamera und gehen sie zum
krankenhaus da ist alles leer
das krankenhaus ist aber nicht leer
sondern überfüllt mit corona patienten
die keine luft mehr bekommen die korona
krise ist inzwischen eine
glaubwürdigkeitskrise
die impfkampagne sollte auch priester
und landärzte einsetzen die
glaubwürdigkeit in den dörfern und
kleinstädten haben
inzwischen helfen eu-staaten mit
medikamenten und beatmungsgeräten noch
nie war die korona krise in rumänien so
dramatisch wie jetzt
und ähnlich problematische situation in
russland auch dort traut die bevölkerung
ihre regierung und dem impfstoff nicht
und damit es geht es jetzt weiter der
hauptstadt moskau werden angesichts
immer neuer höchststände bei den corona
todeszahlen wie der beschränkungen
eingeführt laut moskaus bürgermeister
müssen ungeimpfte über 60 und menschen
mit chronischen erkrankungen vom
kommenden montag an für vier monate
weitgehend zu hause bleiben die
offizielle statistik wie es heute 1015
krone tote aus so viele innerhalb eines
tages wie noch nie in russland mit
insgesamt 146 millionen einwohnern sind
nach jüngsten zahlen erst rund 30
prozent der bevölkerung geimpft
die verhandlungen über eine koalition
von spd grünen und fdp sollen am
donnerstag beginnen in der
arbeitsgruppen werden dazu gebildet
offene fragen gibt es etwa bei der
finanzierung der vorhaben der drei
parteien jetzt haben sich grünen-chefin
berbalk sowie der spd vorsitzende walter
borjans dafür ausgesprochen die
milliarden vorhaben teilweise auch über
kredite zu finanzieren
gleichzeitig soll die schuldenbremse
eingehalten werden
nordkorea hat offenbar erneut eine
rakete getestet nach angaben südkoreas
feuerte das militär eine u boot
gestützte ballistische rakete in
richtung mehr ohne resolutionen
untersagen nordkorea den test von
ballistischen raketen die je nach bauart
auch einen atomsprengkopf tragen können
die us-regierung forderte nordkorea auf
weitere provokationen zu unterlassen
im fall des inhaftierten türkischen
menschenrechtsaktivisten ausmalen kavala
hat die türkei die botschafter
deutschlands und neun weiterer staaten
einbestellt diese hatten gestern in
einem brief die freilassung covers
gefordert ankara bezeichnete die
einmischung als maßlos und inakzeptabel
der unternehmer kavala sitzt seit vier
jahren in haft ihm wird die beteiligung
an den regierungskritischen protesten
2013 sowie dem gescheiterten
militärputsch von 2016 vorgeworfen
der prozess gegen eine ehemalige
sekretärin des kz stutthof wurde heute
fortgesetzt die 96 jährige angeklagte
hatte zunächst versucht sich dem
verfahren zu entziehen beim ersten
verhandlungstag ende september war sie
vor gericht nicht erschienen
stuth hof war ein konzentrationslager
bei danzig in dem zigtausende menschen
qualvoll starben unter anderem in einer
gaskammer
es wird nicht mehr viele solcher
prozesse geben das leben ja nicht mehr
viele derer man juristisch noch habhaft
werden könnte und die verfahren sind
auch nicht unumstritten
einerseits gibt es für diese taten keine
verjährung dass jemand alt ist macht die
schuld nicht geringer und die qualen der
opfer und ihrer angehörigen nicht
weniger
andere sagen solche prozesse kommen
inzwischen zu spät auch für die opfer
der attacke berichtet
ich lebe zwei leben
nicht einen ich lebe mein leben am tag
um lebe mein leben nachts
nachts wenn ich immer noch im lager
was er je damals erlebte im
konzentrationslager stutthof kann er
nicht vergessen den hunger und die
todesangst fühlt er bis heute mehr als
65.000 menschen ermordeten die nazis in
stuttgart tausende schickten sie von
hier nach auschwitz auch noah musste mit
ansehen wie seine mutter und sein
jüngerer bruder von hier nach auschwitz
abtransportiert wurden
weil ich gesehen habe meine mutter und
einen kleinen jungen und auch eine
andere frau mit kindern wusste ich genau
wurde hingegen wusste ich genau bescheid
widersprechen mag
die listen auf denen die namen von der
us mutter und bruder standen die listen
mit den namen der opfer soll irmgard f
abgetippt haben sie war die sekretärin
des lagerkommandanten damals 18 jahre
alt ob sie von den morden im lager
wusste genau das soll der prozess klären
mit 96 jahren muss sich nun wegen
beihilfe zum mord in mehr als 11.000
fällen verantworten das im griff erst
jetzt 75 jahre nach ihrem mutmaßlichen
taten angeklagt wird können viele nicht
nachvollziehen und auch informierte
wissenschaftler kritisieren den prozess
macht man auf und stellt heute die knapp
hundert jahre alt sind vor gericht und
erzeugt damit mitleid mit den tätern
egal in welcher intensität der tat das
ist zwar gut gemeint aber das gegenteil
von gut ist meistens gut gemeint ich
möchte keine märtyrer haben die
eigentlich täter waren
jahrzehntelang verfolgte die deutsche
justiz hilfspersonal aus den
konzentrationslagern nicht erst vor fünf
jahren 2016 bestätigte der
bundesgerichtshof dass auch gehilfen
sich strafbar machen können als teil des
organisierten morgens in den lagern der
nazis das argument
nur durch dieses zusammenwirken wurde es
ermöglicht dass diese massentötung
überhaupt funktioniert haben und dann
kann man sagen auch ein vergleichsweise
kleiner beitrag wie eine sekretärin eine
stenotypistin die diktate aufgenommen
hat hat in dieser art und weise an
diesem gesamtsystem als rädchen im
getriebe eben mitgewirkt diese änderung
der rechtsprechung kommt spät zu spät
findet aber nur deshalb hat er sich im
gegensatz zu vielen anderen stufe
überlebenden der anklage gegen im gav
nicht angeschlossen
hätte man das gemacht zwar 50 jahren
also seit sich ja gleich nach der
befreiung kann ich mir gar nicht
verstehen irgendwie
aber jetzt wie vor sind davon gekommen
richtige ehemalige mörder
mörderin war irmgard f nicht aber sie
hat mutmaßlich mitgeholfen das morden im
kz zu organisieren heute spielt sie zu
den vorwürfen
ob sie tatsächlich schuldig ist soll der
prozess klären
und jetzt macht nochmal heinz weiter mit
anderen meldungen und zuerst die blick
auf die wirtschaft die hohen
energiepreise sind weiterhin eines der
topthemen gerade auch nach dem ja
gestern ein rekordhoch beim dieselpreis
gemeldet wurde da gibt es die sorge vor
schweren folgen für die gesamte
wirtschaft valerie haller ja der
deutsche mittelstand hat sich zu wort
gemeldet und genau für diesen
drastischen folgen für wirtschaft und
verbraucher gewarnt warnt vor höheren
lohnforderungen also einer klassischen
lohn preis spirale und der bundesverband
fordert daher steuersenkungen also
runter mit der mineralölsteuer die
inzwischen energie steuer heißt
zumindest eine zeitlang um den
mittelstand zu entlasten
denn das unternehmen die höheren
spritpreise wenigstens zum teil auf ihre
kunden abwälzen daran dürfte kein
zweifel bestehen spediteure zahlen fast
50 prozent mehr für den sprit als noch
vor einem jahr die ware die sie geladen
haben wird daneben auch zwangsläufig
teurer zu den höheren energiepreisen
kommt der rohstoffmangel laut einer
umfrage der förderbank kfw unter
mittelständlern kämpft fast jedes zweite
unternehmen mit lieferengpässen mehr als
ein viertel sieht sich dazu gezwungen
die preise zu erhöhen dass sich die
lieferengpässe bald legen glauben die
wenigsten ein großteil erwartet dass
sich diese noch bis ins kommende jahr
ziehen der rohstoffmangel ist auch ein
grund warum die auftragsbücher der
industrie immer dicker werden im august
so dick wie seit mindestens sechs jahren
nicht im schnitt brauchen unternehmen
sieben monate um einen auftrag
abzuarbeiten vielen fehlt also schlicht
das nötige material um nach corona
wieder voll durchzustarten ballaballa
vielen dank
nach jahrelangen turbulenzen hat der
regionalflughafen frankfurt-hahn
insolvenz angemeldet zuletzt hatte der
airport in rheinland-pfalz zwar zuwächse
beim frachtgeschäft verbuchte allerdings
gingen die zahlen beim passagiergeschäft
seit jahren zurück der regionalflughafen
gehört mehrheitlich dem chinesischen
großkonzern hna der bereits anfang des
jahres in finanzielle schieflage geraten
war vorerst würden weiter flüge vom
hunsrück aus starten dieses von seiten
der betriebsleitung
es gibt eine unwetterwarnung des
deutschen wetterdienstes vor orkanböen
für teile von sachsen anhalt in lagen
oberhalb von 1000 metern
das olympische feuer für die
winterspiele in peking ist weiter auf
dem weg von griechenland in das
gastgeberland china im panathinaikos
stadion in athen wurde die flamme
offiziell an das chinesische
organisationskomitee übergeben
in dem ganz aus marmor bestimmten
stadion haben vor über 100 jahren die
ersten olympischen spiele der neuzeit
stattgefunden die nächsten winterspiele
finden im februar
2022 statt
die frankfurter buchmesse hat heute ihre
tore geöffnet nicht nur virtuell wie
letztes jahr sondern richtig mit echten
menschen und büchern zwar mit viel
weniger besuchern und ausstellern als im
normalen zeiten aber immerhin es gibt
wieder begegnungen allerdings auch
solche die erneut für kontroversen
sorgen etwa um die frage wann die in
anspruch genommene meinungsfreiheit der
einen die freiheit und sicherheit
anderer beschränkt nie war all berichtet
die frankfurter buchmesse ist wieder da
und mit ihr auch die kontroverse um die
präsenz von verlagen der neuen rechten
wieder sind hier einige vertreten aus
protest dagegen haben jetzt die
autorinnen jasmina kuhnke und annabelle
mandeng ihre messeauftritte abgesagt die
messe verteidigt sich pocht auf die
meinungsfreiheit
rassismus diversität themen die auch das
diesjährige gastland umtreiben kanada
den pavillon gibt es gleich zweimal
physisch in frankfurt und virtuell
virtuell hält auch margaret atwood welt
da der kanadischen literatur ihre
eröffnungsrede
und maschinen für
mitgetragen
kanada weit offen es wirkt wie die pure
verheißung im zweitgrößten land der welt
lieben 38 millionen menschen
unterschiedlichster herkunft mit den
amtssprachen englisch und französisch
vielen denk und lebensweisen die sich in
der literatur spiegeln zwei dieser
diversen stimmen gehören kim tui und fti
duschen bestseller autor innen mit
migrationsgeschichte kim lebt im
französisch sprachigen osten es sie ganz
im englischsprachigen westen als tochter
ghanaischer einwanderer in calgary
geboren fühlte sie sich fremd ihre
romane beleuchten afro amerikanische
geschichte als spiegel der gegenwart
sich sicher fühlen und frei noch immer
nicht selbstverständlich für schwarze in
mehrheitlich weißen gesellschaften auch
nicht im vermeintlich so liberalen
kanada wo selbst premier just didn't
rudow gegen rassismus demonstriert
wir schauen ständig nach süden über die
grenze und sagen so schlimm ist es nicht
auf die amerikaner so beschönigen und
vertuschen wir unseren rassismus
gegenüber schwarzen
kim tui ist
1978 mit ihrer familie aus vietnam
geflohen apa sie ziehen immer wieder
sind sehnsucht heimat und fremde
literarische motive sowie traumatische
kindheitserlebnisse im krieg
die unschuld der kinder offenbart die
grausamkeit des krieges noch besser ich
schreibe oft über kinder die im krieg
geboren wurden aus der verbindung von
zwei fremden natürlich sind sie
zerrissen sie haben keine identität
identität sie entsteht auch durch die
feder der schreibenden nachzulesen in
den büchern dieses literaturherbstes
mehr zur buchmesse und dem gastland
kanada finden sie auf www zdfkultur de
in dem dokumentarfilm kanada lesen das
wasser im heute-journal sehr empfehlen
möchte ich ihnen noch die nachfolgende
37 grad sie stellt heute menschen vor
die eine behinderung haben gerade
deshalb aber über besondere fähigkeiten
verfügen wie sie auch in ihrer
berufstätigkeit mit erfolg einsetzen
und um 0 uhr gibt es dann unser heute
schnell update mit nazan drückte mir auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend das wird morgen ein
ausgesprochen bilder ja fast schon waren
zu nennen der tag allerdings eher kaufen
wir uns das damit dass dann ein
sturmtief dann braust sie sehen dass
hier an den iso barren das sind die
linien gleichen luftdrucks wo die sehr
eng beieinander liegen da wird der wind
besonders heftig sein sie sehen also bis
donnerstag trifft das eigentlich ganz
mitteleuropa besonders heftig wird der
wind aber seien an den küsten von nord-
und ostsee und auf den mittelgebirgs
gipfeln da gibt es sogar orkanartige
orkanböen also windgeschwindigkeiten von
über 100 von über 117 kilometer pro
stunde auch im flachland pfeift es
ordentlich und da die bäume noch voller
blätter sind werden einige umstürzen
oder zumindest erste abreißen heute
nacht verlässt uns eine warmfront in
richtung nordosten dann wird es ruhig
und die temperaturen sinken auf 15 bis 4
grad und morgen erwarten uns dann sehr
lange werte von 17 bis 23 grad und der
tag beginnt erstmal häufig freundlich
mit sonnenschein und wolken dann ziehen
aber schon bald diese dicken regenwolken
heran es gibt kräftige schauer und
gewitter und schon die ersten sturmböen
auch einzelne tornados sind nicht völlig
ausgeschlossen in der nacht zu
donnerstag zieht dieses sturmtief dann
weiter in richtung nordosten und am
donnerstag verlässt es uns dann
nordostwärts danach wird es markant
kelter statt der 17 bis 23 grad morgen
gibt es am samstag nur noch 7 bis 13
grad guten abend